what's up everyone it's Gary Vaynerchuk
doing an interview series with founders
I I'm not making a prediction that I'm
gonna do this often because the truth is
I like to hear myself speak more than I
like to hear other people speak but
figure we're at South by the rock is sad
that I didn't treat many askgaryvee
episodes so I decided to make some
content obviously for the askgaryvee
show meerkat has become a new amazing
addition for the behind the scenes
obviously I've been paying attention to
it very heavily it's been the whole buzz
at South by Southwest
I've been following Ben's career for a
long time since since this product was
an iteration couple of iterations ago so
Ben why don't you tell the vaynernation
a little bit about yourself and what
you're doing now so we're working the
live video space for over two years two
and a half years now I'm trying to
figure out how do we form a new habit
for people to go out of the comfort zone
and live stream because this is
something that people don't do often I'm
27
from Israel originally study look great
you look 24 go ahead and size
architecture I dropped out of college in
my third year to build yevo which was
the first iteration of this product why
he bbl/d rock show show show it how it
used to be good and when we figured out
over the time with yevo we have a grew
to like 400,000 users but we thought
that there's no heartbeat and what we
thought that our vision for this thing
to be is not it's not what it's going to
be so we we go back we went back to our
investor and say you know we're an F
have half of the way down and we think
we should close that flat platform and
we need to do series of iteration based
of what we learned so we set up this
sixth experiment and the first thing
that we put out was meerkat but just
kind of the whole team was working on a
different experience want to friend
which was in big use case of Java and we
could just took off it was built just by
the CTO the client not the back in the
backend we worked a long time on that
and just took off and after five days we
decided to focus the whole team on that
what was the first thing that it was
launched when the taking off started
exactly 16 years 16 days ago 27:27 Oh
February February 27 yeah and since then
Red Bull American Idol Tony Hart the
Secretary of Commerce the governor of
Florida Gary Vaynerchuk Gary Vaynerchuk
why don't we show the leaderboard right
now yeah
Gary Vaynerchuk killed it yesterday with
I think the largest amount of concurrent
Watchers ever more than more than 15,000
was amazing so what what do you think
the biggest misconception is what is the
biggest misconception of meerkat right
now two three weeks in we're just
getting going a lot of opinions you know
Twitter's gonna shut you down periscope
I don't get it why not you stream what's
the biggest misconceptions you're
hearing right now I think the biggest
misconception is under estimating a team
that was with a product outside and had
400,000 users and had the chance to eat
irate and make mistake over and over and
over again in this we had to let go for
foreperson of our staff reduce it it was
he went through a lot of [ __ ] the
biggest misconception is under
estimating how unpolished product could
be and under estimating what a team that
had a product out for two years and
closed the product the try different
thing can do
the context of all those learnings the
context of all this learning just
this is one misconception like this
forget about you know what let me take a
spin off because I think a lot of the
people that watch this are less worried
about where you're going which I think
is right the business world yeah what
about them on a day-to-day basis normal
people yeah let's go that route all
right so this is the biggest
misconception and and people ask why now
why now live stream so we were kids we
had cameras our parents had cameras we
know what to stand out of a good photo
we know how good photo should look like
what is the mindset that would follow
that what are the standards of what it
means a good photo so when a software
substitute came like Instagram it was an
easy transition for the habit-forming to
go to the software side we know what a
good photo should look like we know what
it means life swimming is not we didn't
live stream when we were a kid our
parents didn't live swim and the biggest
misconception
don't worry we're all right
he rocks you yeah
don't worry people are going to rock you
know how I like it
alright then I like it straight all
right I like it live stream no problem I
love it real time from I love the real
[ __ ] why do you think I like what you do
I come on time don't edit tell them
don't let it die rock rock go ahead
alright so in the early 20th century
people didn't smile on picture it was
weird to smile on Victoire in russia in
the 60s and 70s because they were
miserable keep going and that means how
habit needs time to evolve and we're
just now unlocking this habit of live
streaming live streaming how people are
going to be live streaming what does it
mean what is a good stream what does it
mean to be what does it mean to discover
live stream in real time and I think
there is a lot of this for us to learn
and there's a lot of this that we
already learned and I think that the
biggest misconception is thinking that
there is that there is not going to be a
new medium here because because we are
unlocking new sets of habit what
percentage of normal people do you think
don't think live streaming's gonna take
off I don't what's your guess what's
your guess I don't know I I assume a lot
of them because they're not they don't
know what it means to go along they
don't know what it means they know what
you think I just do you think do you
think in live streaming bandido do you
think 12 13 14 15 16 year olds are more
likely to say this is they're happy
because that's the snapshot which is an
amazing company they just went with a
big machete and just pave the road did
you guys go with your yellow color
because of snapchat
no because because meerkat is in the
Kalahari Desert and it's very
and it's just like made sense and then
the first time we said like oh [ __ ] did
we made a mistake it's when you try to
open a meerkat and you open snapchat and
then you say and then I came to worry
and he said I said to him worry I think
I think I think maybe maybe it's not a
good idea that it's yellow and he said
good it came from a very true place in
their heart and soul leave it that way
so leave it that place yeah yeah good
luck to you my friend thank you guys
thank you for having me cat it up